la nuit isabelle frappier parle pour la
première fois depuis trois semaines à sa
fille de 14 ans floriane coincé au
sénégal depuis que le vol de retour de
son groupe a été annulé en tout ils sont
quinze étudiants de 14 à 16 ans de
l'école secondaire saint joseph à
saint-hyacinthe qui termine ces jours de
coopération internationale depuis 36 ans
c'est le branle bas de combat pour le
trouver un plan b qu'on a dû nous faire
toutes sortes de démarches dans le fond
pour trouver une alternative à leur
retour puisque ils sont confinés au
sénégal présent pas la solution cinq
jeunes quitteront demain soir avec un
adulte en passant par le togo et les
états unis
dix autres et deux adultes reviendront
par paris et amsterdam mercredi soir en
tout plus d'une quarantaine d'heures de
voyagement au mieux floriane sera donc
au pays vendredi soir pour sa mère c'est
très très long tout à coup que ça ferme
qu'est ce qu'on va faire on sent
vraiment démunis en cinq ans
voudrait faire quelque chose mais qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire c'est ce qui est
difficile
jean françois racine a demandé une
intervention du fédéral dimanche soir
faut se rappeler que ce sont des mineurs
il ya un niveau d'inquiétude de la part
des parents de la part des jeunes
pour l'instant sa demande est restée
sans réponse affaire mondiale nous ont
transmis certaines informations mais on
sait pas ce qu'ils peuvent faire pour
nous aider présente le député de la
région également écrit au ministre
champagne ce matin et moi je pense qu'il
ya toutes sortes de démarches peuvent
être fait que ce soit être fait que ce
soit au niveau diplomatique mais aussi
au pire s'il faut aller jusqu'à nolisé
un avion parce qu'on parle encore une
fois de jeunes mineurs je pense qu'il
faut l'envisager
en l'absence d'internet durant le voyage
les étudiants n'étaient pas au courant
de la situation au québec
le retour sur terre pourrait être
difficile on pourra partir de ce prix
avec toute la famille floriane parce que
tout le monde faut qu'on soit isolé non
vous pourrez pas sortir et vous allez
être obligé d'être un carré interne
confinées à la maison ici norma grondin
radio canada montréal